there's a worthy successor to Game of
Thrones for your new medieval fantasy
obsession as the authorial legend of the
Lady of the lake gets an epic
reimagining in cursed yippie ki movie
lovers I'm jammin in this video and
revealing what the show run is left out
from the ending of cursed and how it
reveals the truth about NIMH waste fate
Plus why some character deaths may not
be what they first seem spoilers ahead
of course so take care if you're not all
caught up at the end of curse the creepy
religious fanatic IRA shoots a pair of
arrows in TuneIn way sending her
plunging into the waterfall below but
the big question is whether NIMH way is
dead or alive
the ending was foreshadowed in the very
first episode when a deer was shot dead
with an arrow right in front of NIM way
and it was also foreshadowed in the many
recurring visions she has of herself
sinking into a pool of bloody water with
arrow stuck in her body but what's
missing from the finale is a crucial
epilogue scene from the book on which
the Netflix show is based in which we
discover that NIMH wait does indeed
survive the book by Tom wheeler and
Frank Miller reveals that NIMH waives
body washed up on a sandbar in the
shadows of the minitor mountains the
arrow in her back had broken off to a
stump the other arrows were bent under
her weight her breath came in he being
intervals and there are some subtle
details in the TV show that support the
idea that NIMH way will survive her fall
into the water in the very final scene
iris takes up her new position in the
church as Trinity guard but shots of
NIMH way sinking below the water rapidly
cut in and crucially gasping breathing
sounds have been mixed into the audio
and if you pause on some of those
flashes you'll also see that in in ways
eyes have opened on top of that mixed in
tune in ways visions are glimpses of her
underwater but swimming back up to the
surface the perk also tells us what
happens after nin way washes up on the
shore something moved near her dozens of
bodies swayed over NIM way blistered
hands some missing fingers pushed and
probed at her the ghoulish hands reached
underneath NIM ways body and lifted her
into the air the leper mob swarmed her
limp body and spirited it into a dark
and foreboding tunnel the leper mob
mentioned here are the gruesome militia
that serves rügen the leper king and are
the ones who came to take Merlin away to
meet the dark shadow lord if NIM way
does end up captured by the leper king
in the second season but it's worth
remembering this her father Merlin is
now Rubens enemy after the Wizards stole
the Fae fire from his Hall of treasures
so how didn't him way survive a steep
drop into water with two arrows stuck in
her well regardless of whether she has
the sword or not Nimoy has access to
some incredibly strong magic as a child
she saved herself from certain death
when she was viciously attacked by a
giant demon bur after her mother
telepathically told her to summon the
help of the hidden chapter and with that
power she was able to bring down a huge
rock to crush the giant Birds girl and
as the first season progresses she moves
from struggling to control her ability
when she's angry to being able to call
on it at will such as when she uses the
woods to attack a small army of
paladin's that she draws into a trap
although I fully expect an in way to
survive she may end up transformed into
something else by her drowning for a
hint
let's examine in ways vision from the
fourth episode when she's almost drowned
by a red paladin in this premonition
after she sees herself sinking into
bloody water there's a shot of some
bloody hands rising up to grab some
branches and if you look very closely
these hands even have little green
shoots or foliage growing on the fingers
is this limb way dying and then rising
again in different form in the first
episode just before the deer is shot NIM
way hears a voice telling her death is
not the
and fate queen if Nimoy is reborn after
drowning it seems likely that she is now
the lady of the lake the fabled
enchantress who in the original legends
gifts Arthur the magical sword Excalibur
there's a big hint in the book that this
is what the writers may have in mind for
the series in the novel as Nimoy feels
herself slipping away under the cold
water she thinks to herself this was my
vision I will keep the sword safe
neither the church nor Uther nor cumber
will have it the war of the sword dies
with me until a true King rises to claim
it as for Gawain while he's another main
character who we shouldn't presume is
actually permanently dead when nimah
discovers he's died from the torture
inflicted on him by the red paladin she
cries out in grief at the loss of her
dear friend unleashes an incredible
amount of power then collapses spoiler
alert for Avengers age of Ultron this
moment reminds me of Scarlet Witch in
that film after her brother dies later
in cursed though when the paladins come
to cart' often in way look carefully
because there are now golden leaves and
shoots that have grown on his skin and
then a massive green grass and leaves
grow up from the ground around him to
encase him presumably to form some kind
of protection or cocoon until he's ready
to be reborn in cursed Gawain is also
known as the Green Knight and in some of
the Arthurian legends the Green Knight
is green skinned so it'll be interesting
to see if this is something as
showrunners plan for Gawain when he
rises again I think Gwen's revival will
prove that Nimoy actually has the power
to bestow life remember that she was
able to make a withered old fruit tree
grow in abundance of apples and when
Merlyn asked her what she had done to
make this happen she told him I thought
about someone I loved could go and be
the person she was thinking of
platonically in that moment and perhaps
because of the grief she felt at losing
him she unknowingly brought him back to
life by wishing he hadn't died and what
if as Nimoy was drowning she recalled
this advice from Merlyn to draw upon the
powers of the Hidden I imagine the
result you walk create an intention and
then surrender their intention to the
hidden the idea of rebirth and
transformation isn't solely limited to
nim way and waning cursed for example
Morgana is infected by the spider god
the Kali
when she meets a vision of her dead
girlfriend Celia maganda then becomes a
powerful sorceress when she kills the
deathly Widow and transforms into that
character in case you missed it it
happens during the animated transition
after widow catches Morgana the sword
first pierces the widow and kills her
but then the widow's essence or spirit
seems to enter Morgana and take her over
this moment completes Morgana's
transformation into Morgan la Fey the
powerful enchantress from the Arthurian
legends the weeping monk also transforms
from being a weapon of evil and
destruction for the church and converts
back to his original feign Eicher taking
back his real name Lancelot Merlin - is
renewed after picking up the sword going
from a mortal and magic 'lest Rickster
to finally getting his mojo back
including some impressive lightning
powers when he goes all thor ragnarok on
the red paladin's squirrel has also
graduated to the position of a knight by
proving his bravery to Gawain and with
the reveal that his real name is
Percival this sets him up to be the
Grail Knight from the legends there's
also the diminutive but deadly iris who
rises from the status of an ordinary nun
who had to take orders from sister crane
- becoming a member of the Pope's
fearsome Trinity Guard together we
should accomplish great miracles my
child
and let's not forget Arthur - who begins
the show as a liar and thief who hangs
around with lowlife mercenaries like
Bors but ends up as a leader and
protector of the Fae people even willing
to sacrifice himself for them
Arthur also saves red spheres life
during the battle with cumbers army and
the meeting between these two at the end
sets up a future storyline I am the red
spear exile of the court have come of
the Ice King I'm Arthur I will do all in
our power to help your people if you
help save our queen in the book red
spear introduces herself to Arthur as
Guinevere in this moment something that
doesn't happen in the show in the
Arthurian legends winner veer is
actually Arthur's wife and queen so
it'll be interesting to see if there
will be any hints at romance between
Arthur and red spear next season and how
NIM way might react to that if she finds
out so what did you think of the first
season of
and which for your favorite moments and
characters let me know in the comments
below
next on Netflix is the Umbrella Academy
and Lucifer so make sure you subscribe
to get notified about my videos on those
as soon as I upload them and if you
enjoyed this I really appreciate a
thumbs up and a share tapleft my full
Netflix playlist or tap write for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yep you go movie lovers